Continuing
in
in the chapter regarding the obligations
of wuboo.
So yesterday we spoke about
washing the hands from the tips of the
fingers
all the way up the forearms to include
the elbows.
We discussed that in some detail.
And now the author goes into the third
obligation of
he says
He says the third is wiping the head
entirely, the whole head
and the ears are part of the head.
So let's unpack this statement here.
Wiping over the entirety of the head.
The wiping over the head is to take
place from where the
washing of the face ended. The place
where washing the face stopped. This is
where the wiping over the head begins.
And the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam
would most usually
wipe his head one time going back.
Right? So he'd start at the front and he
would work his way back. Now before
doing this he would wet his hands.
If a person were to say,
you know, I'll just wash my head
instead,
right? If wiping is good, then washing
is better. It doesn't work that way.
It would be saying if
is good, then five is better. It doesn't
work that way. It must be wiping. And
wiping in the Arabic language is that
there is water on the hands and the
hands are run over the entirety of the
of the head, right? Over the entirety of
the head.
And so
most of the time he had long hair except
for Omra. And so he would wipe put put
the water on his hands, right? And then
he would start this with both of
his hands and he would wipe from the
front to the back.
That's it. That is how he would wipe his
head. On occasion,
he would go back and then forward. So he
would wipe back and then come forward
again.
And this is actually kind of a hangup
for
the wording in a lot of these
narrations
because some companions said
he then describing his woo he then would
wipe his head
by bringing them
forward and then back. So he gives you
the imagery of what of starting back
here going forward and then back. But
that's not what the narrator intends.
The narrator intends that from his
perspective he's standing behind him
watching the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam make
to the prophet sallall.aii wasallam.
He's going back and then forward to the
onlooker. He's coming forward with his
hands and then back. But he was not
narrated to have authentically and
clearly started from the back of his
head. He always starts from the front.
He would either wipe it once or
sometimes he would wipe once and then
back. There is a third narration in
surah dud which articulates that he
wiped his head three times three the
narration of armed however the
authenticity of this narration is
contested if it is authentic it is a
very rare thing that he would wipe three
times over his head
and then he would do the ears without
taking water again without wetting his
hands again. So from wiping his head,
he would put his index fingers into his
ears and his thumbs behind the ears and
he would wipe all that part of the ear
that is
that is protruding, you know. So he
would wipe the entirety of the ear.
So he would wipe the fronts of the ears
with his f index fingers and the backs
of his ears with his thumbsatam.
And the ears is like
the mouth and nose to the face. The ears
to the head are the mouth and nose
are to the face. in the sense that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says wash your face
and every single time he made woo he
washed or rinsed his mouth and nose. So
that means that he understood that the
mouth and nose are part of what part of
the face and what else would they be
really right? What else would they be?
Likewise, the ears, the ears are part of
the head. And so every single time he
made wudoo, he would never fail to wipe
his ears.
am. And furthermore,
in a narration which has many chains of
narration and it was reported by and
many others on the authority of
the prophet sallall.aii
said
he said the ears are part of the head.
So it's very clear.
Now this is the idyllic
way to wipe over the head and this is
how he would always wipe over his head.
The difference of opinion amongst the
scholarship of Islam and the mad
all of them agree
that the head is to be wiped. All of
them agree that the best wiping of the
head is all of the head entirely.
And as we mentioned before,
90% of the differences of opinion
amongst the mahib
is not what's right or wrong. It's what
is right and what's better. And it's not
what's wrong, but what's wrong and
what's worse. Details. The difference of
opinion is not in this that I just
described to you. That is across the
board. The difference of opinion is the
bare minimum.
What is the bare minimum? So
for instance, he said the bare minimum
is any part of the head even if just on
his temple that. That's enough cuz
technically he wiped his head, right?
And it all comes down to what we
understand the sentence to mean in the
Arabic language.
[Silence]
And in the
it is a fourth a fourth of the head. If
you do a fourth of the head, 3/4s is
better. But 1/4 is the bare minimum.
Said just any part of the head. And this
again goes down to what we understand
the to mean in Allah's words.
So some of the scholars they say here
means
meaning and wipe over a part of your
heads. That's what it would translate
to.
Whilst others
say
[Silence]
means wipe over your heads with water on
your hands.
That's an that's another meaning here
for the be and we see this meaning used
elsewhere in the Quran. So for instance
in
[Silence]
And so based on how they understood this
bell is what they understood the bare
minimum to be. None of them contested
how the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
wiped over his head. How is that? He
would wipe over all of his head if it
was exposed. The only instance we find
that he did not wipe over the entirety
of his head is when he was wearing
something on his head. That is the only
time. There is no narration that is
authentic and clear.
That in all the years he made wool, he
wiped over a portion of his head
when his head was uncovered. Never.
only when
when he would have something on his head
and not just something on his head like
a hat I have a hat on my head now.
When it is something that is complex and
requires
to be wrapped and made up.
And this is why some scholars say a
person cannot wipe over his turban
unless his turban is
mucca.
Meaning that the turban is wrapped in
such a way that there is complexity and
it wraps under the under the chin.
So that if he had to make woo, he'd have
to take all this thing off to wipe over
his head and then put it all back on
again and wrap it all up again. And this
is a a kind of hindrance, right?
And so only on that occasion when he had
this kind of turban on, he would wipe
whatever is showing of his head and then
finish the wiping over the turban.
But never once was he narrated to have
his head uncovered making mood and then
only wipe over a portion of his head.
And this again goes down to what bare
minimum technically. What is the bare
minimum?
Remember we spoke about this a few days
ago when we spoke about the mouth and
nose
that if something is not obligatory,
he will at least one time not do it in
order to what? Articulate that it is
better and not
absolutely mandatory.
But here we don't have that. So we
understand from this that he understood
that anytime your head is bare, you are
wiping over all of the head.
And if someone has something on their
head, a woman has her hijab on the
prophet sallallah.aii's alaihi
wasallam's wives and others they would
as well wipe over their hijab
just he would wipe over his turban.
However, if the head is exposed, the
wiping is for the entirety of the head
and the ears are what? Part of the head.
Foreham
[Silence]
death children.
Yesterday they messed with the
microphone again
and that's why and that's why
[Arabic recitation]
giving
the switches
already.
[Silence]
It should have been on.
What about
that?
[Silence]
Never felt someone
Why did you not expect?
[Arabic recitation]
Well, I tell them I don't I don't have a
loss of words when I
and then they
But the second
is that
they cross the first row.
They get a little,
you know, because they're leaving their
kids their kids are just cows like
we put all this money and all this
is
You know, I mean, it's it's so
obnoxious.
[Silence]
Eventually
left because you said he'll break the
equipment in the midst
[Silence]
and then it's not
They had no intention.
They came
with them.
It's not
This is why
of the opinions of scholars.
[Silence]
They are unable.
Not
here.
Okay.
is one of
[Silence]
popular
Back here
number 68.
You
mention
the third column mention
in the fourth column mentions.
So anytime you go to read
[Silence]
Now, it's not going to distinguish
something.
[Silence]
kind of fashion
that will have the
chapter title. It will have the
Number
of verses in the chapter.
[Silence]
We can tell by the chapter we can tell
by the chapter
after
the migration.
actually
[Silence]
love you.
All the stories are
probably after
I would do that.
[Silence]
All
heaven
[Silence]
Now
All right.
[Silence]
Are you
God's word.
[Silence]
How did you
say
arms and legs? It is a
And you are not
[Silence]
loved.
Everything
[Silence]
right here.
innovators that came.
[Silence]
Created words of the Almighty.
This will be a creation.
[Silence]
Thank you.
You are
[Silence]
take it for granted.
So this process
ever seen a boxer
for
any other
competition that it comes down.
[Silence]
They don't
know what I'm supposed to be doing.
Lots of lots of praise.
[Silence]
Not because they're super smart.
Practice, practice, practice.
I had to put in
a lot. I used to be so
I have practiced
[Silence]
That's why
don't
say
literally translates to
intensely struggle in order to
first
endless practice.
That's right.
Even the words
[Silence]
probably
less than about 5 hours a day.
[Silence]
That's
never
going to be proud.
or you get
young men.
[Silence]
very
I spent many years with him. That's the
first one I ever
sat down
[Silence]
I'm going to show you
What did I learn?
[Silence]
I disagree.
I didn't have the
learn
of humility that goes into it.
I'm kind of like
[Silence]
that's what they start.
far more advanced than I am.
Amen.
There is no comparison.
All good
[Silence]
enough.
This works.
This chapter was a real
[Silence]
for
Hello together.
Happy
[Silence]
in there.
get those kind of places.
Go out of your way.
S.
Okay.
[Arabic recitation]